now it's time to touch down briefly in  Rhode Island with pilot Ken peach was  about to land this plane on a moving RV  wait really is that even possible  [Music]  this stunt requires unimaginable skill  so how did can turn a truck into his own  personal runway the guy's has to match  the speed of the plane as it lands with  the speed of the truck the speeds are  exactly right  then you're gonna get problems it's  gonna fall off the back all the planes  gonna roll off the film yeah you think  that's the hard part but it's not the  reason why this is so dangerous has to  do with side winds because when they  come in they can create aerodynamic  instabilities that could flip the plane  over you get crosswind and it's hitting  the side of the truck that will deflect  up and actually create an extra force on  one side of his wing and if he's got an  imbalance in terms of air pressure under  his wing it's gonna make him turn so he  wants to make sure there's no crosswinds  involved